♫ ["Sweet Child o' Mine"
by Guns N' Roses] ♫
THOR
There's a maniac who seeks to end us all.
I'm putting together
the greatest team ever.
JANE FOSTER
Are you packed?
Yes!
[Goats screaming]
♪♪
THOR
We've got Korg...
KORG
He's my best friend!
THOR
Yes!
There's my ex-girlfriend Jane...
THOR
Valkyrie...
VALKYRIE
This is the best day of my life!
THOR
The Guardians...
GROOT
I am Groot!
[Goats screaming]
KORG
And giant goats!
THOR
Oh, look at those, they are wonderful!
KORG
Yes, they are.
They also scream quite a lot.
[Goat screaming]
♫ Oh, oh, oh, oh
Sweet child of mine ♫
ROCKET
You said this would be a relaxing holiday!
THOR
I said it was going to be
"like" a relaxing holiday.
♫ Whoa, oh
Sweet child of mine ♫
THOR
Human handshake, to the Asgardian shake,
into the snake
that you cannot trust... [Hisses]
PETER QUILL
You're really dragging this out.
THOR
...finish with the classic
Asgardian High One.
[Mimicking explosion]